minutes nathan mais pourquoi tu as fait
ça c'est facile à réparer juger un
tournevis dans la voiture au visage
d'une carrière d'humoriste je raconte
des blagues
c'est effrayant moi c'est sûr ça j'ai un
ami qui a toujours voulu faire de la
comédie mais c'était une lettre
meilleurs amis n'avez pas idée à quel
point je prends la plupart du temps on
aurait dit qu'ils étaient mariés et
j'étais simple spectatrice
[Musique]
salut les filles et vibrant cher quand
tu vois fatigué merci d'être venus
montrer pas ça
blatt est ce qu'on peut se parler un
moment la combinaison de la maladie de
médicaments va provoquer des réactions
jamais vu avant je pourrai vous aider à
traverser ça m'a beaucoup ça
j'espère pas plus que quelques semaines
je veux juste m'assurer que matt se
remettre sur pied
je prépare les déjeuners des trucs que
moi je peux enlever un peu de ce poids
j'espérais que dorénavant tu pourrais
m'appeler grand-maman des vies c'est pas
une réponse qui je t'appelle grand-maman
day merci tu veux faire mais je voudrais
écrire des lettres aux filles pour les
grandes étapes de leur vie
au revoir les cheveux longs voiles et tu
vas me dire quand ça va commencer à
l'arrière qui se passait toute sa vie
elle a voulu être grand maréchal du
mardi gras
oui je veux chanter sur scène avec katy
perry se semble assez faisable tu crois
est parti depuis trois mois déjà
je croyais que tu allais est reparti
pour quelques semaines qu'est ce qui a
changé j'ai tout de suite réalisé qu'une
personne pouvait faire ça tout seul je
ne crois pas que tu es en colère parce
que j'ai 15 minutes de retard
la maman je crois que tu es en colère
parce que maman est malade
quand t'es dur avec ton père il vient de
briser mon corps jetés de sourire les
gens évitent de me regarder quand il ma
part de la plus belle femme que j'ai
jamais vu tu le seras toujours
[Musique]
t'es pas obligé de rester non plus
nicole c'est mon ami aussi ça me fait
plaisir d'être là
[Musique]